is there a text message that you're like
damn i wish
i didn't delete that oh rogan's text so
i can hold it against him and get some
of that spotify money
welcome back season two it's the
premiere it's going down
tacos contolo and i know you're thinking
it looks a little different
covet today we got a very special
episode
what happens when you take
la makina or machine throw it in there
you get a little bit of tex-mex style
tacos
throw it in there and then you get some
heavy metal tacos
oh almost ripped a bag get it heavy
metal
and a little bit of comedy
get in there shake it up
season two tacos con todo bur crisis
episode
let's get into it
[Music]
i'm here with my good friend my compadre
mr bert lamachina crasher
[Laughter]
what's up bro how you doing i love it
i'm doing great man hold up in the man
cave your man cave looks great this is
my cave right here i'm i'm out in the
wilderness on a picnic table and uh
uh some some camper that i that i never
camper by the way i know that camper
really
i didn't know this camper how mad for
galon said
what have you been doing to uh during
quarantine have you been have you been
on the treadmill i've been on the
treadmill
ridiculously you want to know my mileage
jesus i was just gonna ask i know you're
keeping track that's what i wanted to
ask
drum roll please 798 miles to date
wow when did you start that though
january january 1st january 1st i had a
big day run
you've run a marathon with me you know
you know how my brain works that mickey
mantle gene
is not a joke tried and true
that was the hardest i've ever laughed
we're running through silver lake and i
said to you i said
whatever they give you to eat or drink
eat it and drink it you're like really i
go all of it jesus we're gonna need the
calories
everything they give you so we're eating
bananas we're eating oranges
we're drinking anything i see you
you ran out of your way over to the
right to go grab
a tongue depressor full of vaseline i
thought it was vanilla custard it was
like vanilla goo
or something i was like i wonder if he's
getting a rat and you came back
just holding the tongue under pressure
you're like that tastes like [ __ ]
i was crying laughing like that was
vaseline and you're like i can't get it
off the roof of my mouth
yeah it's so hard to get out because i
went to go get water and the water just
rappelled off my tongue
it's just it's the heart it's one of the
hardest i've ever left
and it was the hardest i've ever pooped
hey man without further ado i think we
should uh chow down on some tacos what
do you say oh
hell yes my name is elvia guerta
i'm part owner of evoco my name is alex
and i'm from queretaro mexico
i've been living here in la for 20 years
we're just trying to rock the
taco world and we decided to call evil
cooks because the devil is in the
details
at the beginning when i started i
decided that i wanted to do molecular
gastronomy but
it was too expensive and it wasn't uh
affordable for everyone
so i was like let's something that fills
up
our soul and why not tackles because
that's
our roots when i was in high school i
wanted to play in a band
and so i was like why not to do
something like related with music
food because at the end music and food
are in the same level
there are it's uh traditional with a
twist
nortecos are what makes your grandma say
what the [ __ ] is that
we serve black pastor chilaquiles
burrito carnitas plant taco churro taco
we have arawas frescas de mazapan
in the black pastor originally a chef in
mexico from yucatan
made it his name is roberto solis we
reach out to
zing that's his restaurant and they give
us a green light to do it here in the
lakes marinade that we use is called
ricado negro from yucatan mexico
what you do you get cacao chilies main
tortilla burn all these spices and make
them to a paste
it's topped with cilantro onions
guacamole
and our spicy salsa we stamp our
tortillas the old technique in uh
from where i'm from in queretaro mexico
what they do they
stamp their tortillas when they have a
big party the spices that we burn
we make into ash and we get the ashes
and
stammed the tortillas serve tacos in a
in a stage with the band behind us
we will do it tacos come on
[Laughter]
check these out these are al pastor
tacos and they look a little darker than
normal you know their theme is very like
goth like
this is like the the formative years of
slipknot look at that
just like it's very god you know we all
have our goth face mine was in high
school and
and right now tacos are having their
goth face look at this and this
my man is not a breaded salmon taco this
is a
flan taco i love
flan i think it's because i grew up in
tampa and that was like what you'd have
when you went over to a cuban kid's
house to spend the night that's what you
got for dessert
and that's not like a white that's not a
white guy treat normally no
no no your tastebuds don't know what to
do with that they're just like what is
this
i want you to walk me through your order
what do you got over there this is
um home state i love their tacos they've
got
the trinity is the best one they've got
the guadalupe
the brisket is phenomenal and these are
all texas style tacos right they got the
flower tortilla
and they've got the different meals
there and they're so
dude making your own tortilla is a game
changer it's a game changer because
that's the canvas of the art
oh amazing take a look at this it's egg
bacon wow it's a perfect breakfast
it's like a perfect breakfast taco their
hot sauces are fantastic i go red and
green and shout out to la taco
for letting us know about evil cooks
oh man
can we get a moment of silence
evil cook skill this [ __ ]
there is something also beautiful about
putting all your artwork
into such a small canvas like
i remember the first time i got a big
burrito and i remember seeing that being
like this is
everything i wanted mexican food to be
then when i came out here and they were
like
no no no no no it's just like a little
pinch of meat a little bit of
a little bit of cilantro less is more
it's big dick energy it's confidence
tacos are confidence
are you eating these tacos what comes to
mind they speak to my
inner white trash like the florida part
of me that is
always going to be garbage speaking of
which they've got this
frito garbage pail that is
garbage cheese it is just like it is
everything i want
jalapenos sour cream
it feels healthy it looks healthy i'm
thinking this
is healthy but then you get a bite
you're like oh this is too good to be
healthy
you think it's healthy because of the
guac in there because i see the sour
cream that's kind of
that looks healthy right
oh my god this is brisket you know
brisket we are on the tour bus dave
makes brisket
nonstop take a look at that bad [ __ ]
the the tortilla
is probably tortilla tortillas are a
brilliant
delivery system the communion should
have been like
tortillas like if they just if if
well i know you have some hot food takes
i sent you a video
and i want you to take a look at it it's
a heated food debate
in the food world that we got going on
i'm gonna throw it to my good friend
my correspondent mr sean evans
all right guys here's one that hits
really close to home so a few years ago
i attacked a taco from the top
and i haven't heard the end of it since
still getting roasted on the internet
about it to this day so my question is
this
is there a right way and a wrong way to
eat a taco
i don't think so i don't tell anyone how
to eat their wings and by the way
free tea pain eating burritos sideways
let's get on the wave all right but what
do you guys think there's no rules with
hard sell tacos
heart chill tacos are chaos once you
bite into them it's a chit chow
everything's every man for himself
they start crumbling very seldomly if i
had a hard start taco where i
ate it beginning to end without making
an absolute mess
what i do with hardshell tacos a lot of
times
is i'll take one of the tops one of the
sides off right
take it all over okay like an open-faced
taco
right and then and then i take it and i
squeeze it like two
like two tortilla chips with all the
meat
like a tortilla chip sandwich a mexican
s'more if you will
then i'll put it all in my mouth i'll
put it all in my mouth so i want to get
into like a little bit of comedy talk
you were
one of the first you were the first
comedian
to ever do drive-in movie theaters you
know looking back on those first two
weeks
what did that feel like but it was scary
other comics
i don't think wanted to do it and i
don't think they still want to do it i
think
right now with with things being so
uncertain is i don't want to be a guinea
pig
like say to me i don't want to be the
first one out there and then fail
and by the way if it's say we went out
and we did
six shows and they were all horrible
that is just a hilarious story down the
road
that is just a story of me being a [ __ ]
i think so many people are afraid to
look like an idiot
i am i am totally fine looking like an
idiot i'm a comic i don't have
my only goal is to make you giggle if
you're going through some [ __ ] you know
some of your families got covered or
you had to put your dog down if i can
give you
five minutes of reprieves from that
where you just laugh
and you don't think about the thing
that's bumming you out that's my job
that's my only job in this world that
tour was just amazing i got over a fear
of swimming
i had my first swimming lesson 30
minutes later we're tubing
i feel like i got the courage to jump in
there and by the end of it
we're swimming in a uh lake
yeah i think as comics we always deal
with this like fear
of this fear of that fear of rejection
and for you to just
moving forward and i i don't know if it
goes back to birth to conquer days or
travel channel days where it's like you
organically were pushed into
uncomfortable situations that you just
you know made your own you just kind of
took life by the horns
on that note what advice would you give
a young comic or
you know i for the longest time i wanted
to be
like other people dane cook was
successful
and i thought the more i kind of
reminded people of dane cook it sounds
bad to say but like
that i i didn't want to like steer fear
off and do my own thing
if i was a young comic i would ignore
the notes of everyone older than you and
do
just what you think is funny like look
at reggie watts like that is a guy who
marches
to his own drum beat and he's and he's
putting it in a loop himself he is so
different
zach galifianakis playing the piano and
singing in a in an orphan annie costume
they do the thing that they find funny
and there's so many of us myself
included i did what i thought the crowd
wanted
to see done and man the second you stop
giving a [ __ ] about that and just start
doing your own thing
it's amazing you just start it's people
start noticing and
it's so freeing and now i just do what i
want to do bert la makina i want to
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for being here thank you for
your time thank you for being you and
best of luck out there man
this is tacos contodo season premiere i
love you brother thank you jesus that
was a blast man
we'll see you next time
[Music]
to whom it may concern
who talks like that i don't talk like
that
dear friends man oh man am i happy to be
back for season two of tacos con todo
season one was fun but this is gonna be
even more funner
claps in spanish evil cooks is like
nothing i've tasted before
i hope you guys get a chance to go taste
their food sometime
if you do tell them we at tacos contolo
said hello
p.s i love pota diablo's vest
do you think he'll trade me for mine
your friend
jesus trejo